he world. This
completely erratic Adhd, uh, foreign policy
is a danger and an embarrassment. We're bombing
people. We're not bombing people all without
even understanding anything and having caused
this problem himself, most importantly. And
now this has really brought some bad faith
right wingers out of the woodwork because
of the, from some on the right has been, wait
a second, you antiwar lefties are now criticizing
Trump for not bombing Iran. This is the most
bad faith discussion that I could imagine.
I mean, just shut up. Seriously. You don't
even deserve a seat at the table if that's
going to be your argument.
The problem is not that Donald Trump didn't
bomb someone and I wanted them bombed. I don't
want Trump bombing Iran in the same way that
I don't want Trump getting involved in Venezuela
or whatever else. The problem is Trump created
this situation. He has no idea what he's doing.
He ordered a strike without initially considering
the civilian casualties. And then last minute
he's told 150 people will die. And then he
says, oh, well let's not do that. As opposed
to asking in the beginning about civilian
casualties, civilian casualties. If it was
a make or break for Trump, which do we believe
that it was? I don't know. But if it was a
make or break for trunk trunk, it should have
been asked about upfront. The absurdity and
the cost of launching this only to later discuss,
discuss casualties and then call it off is
ridiculous. It's embarrassing and it's pathetic.
Now there are other possibilities if you don't
believe that civilian casualties is actually
the real explanation for Donald Trump calling
this off. One general one is, is this some
kind of four d chess by Donald Trump, uh,
where he is wanting to convey willingness
to do this but then canceling it because he
doesn't want the political repercussions and
he gets all the benefit of bombing Iran without
the actual civilian casualties. No evidence
of that. No evidence that Donald Trump is
even capable of that type of abstract thought.
So I don't buy that one. The second idea that's
being floated, and I'm going to dig into this
more tomorrow, is did Putin get in touch and
say don't bomb Iran. And that actually could
relate to a lot of different things I want
to discuss with you. One component is, uh,
the idea of this actually goes back to the
Marshall Plan of the u s in Russia working
together on nuclear with Saudi Arabia being
involved by putting a ton of money and ultimately
getting nuclear technology out of the deal
because there is a long standing, uh, there,
there is a history about Saudi Arabia and
nuclear weapons in the context of Russia and
Iran.
And the idea is that Trump backing out of
the Iran deal to get Iran to restart enrichment
to justify attacking Iran could all be a backdoor
way to justify getting nuclear weapons for
Saudi Arabia into the region. The Saudi Arabian
royal family have previously said, if Iran
gets them, we're getting them. So this is
another entire idea as well. But again, I've
not seen evidence that Donald Trump is capable
of that type of abstract thought wouldn't
be required if Putin or whoever just said,
don't, don't do it. Don't bomb Iran. Um, and
this, there's a, there's an interesting growing
theory that ultimately Donald Trump, despite
his threats, will not attack Iran and we'll
not get into Venezuela and will not do anything
more in Syria because not doing anything they're
in all three of those places would be what
Putin would want. But we'll talk about that
and analyze that more tomorrow.
So here's what I came away with from this
entire fiasco over the weekend as center,
right as Hillary Clinton is and was. And as
much as I wanted someone much more progressive
and voted for Bernie Sanders in the 2016 Democratic
primary, consider that on three major bullet
points alone, we would be much better off
with Hillary Clinton than we are with Donald
Trump. And this goes, I know that most people
in our audience understand this, but there
are still some people, some stragglers remaining
in our audience who are of the Hillary Trump.
It makes no difference to me sort of thing.
Hillary Clinton was going to stay in the Iran
deal, which Iran was complying with, which
means Iran wouldn't now be resuming uranium
enrichment and she would not have ordered
a strike on them and then called it back.
Like none of this would've happened with Iran
if Hillary Clinton had been president number
to Hillary Clinton would've appointed to center
left Supreme Court justices who would now
be on the court for decades rather than two
right wing nuts like Donald Trump has done
that would have had decades of political implications.
We would have been exponentially better off
under Hillary Clinton than Donald Trump. And
then number three, Hillary Clinton would not
have willy nilly started a trade war with
China while cutting taxes on the rich and
corporations period. Yes, Hillary Clinton
would have done things that I would not have
liked. Uh, yes, Hillary Clinton would have
done things that would not have gone nearly
far enough. She would have done some sprinkling
of crumbs while the cake stays mostly in the
same hands, much like Joe Biden would do.
But on those three issues I just mentioned
alone trade, the supreme court and this Iran
stuff, we would be so much better off right
now under Hillary Clinton than we are under
Donald Trump. Disagree with me. Change my
mind. I'm on Twitter at d pacman. The show
is on Twitter at David Pakman show, and we
have just a massive program today. I will
be talking about after the break about what
is incredibly a debate.
There's a debate now over whether caged children
should have soap and bedding. Okay? That's
a debate that is taking place in our country
right now. Thanks to the Trump justice department.
I will also talk to you about these very disturbing
revelations that Donald Trump threatened a
reporter with prison over a photograph, and
then later on in the program, there are new
rape allegations against Donald Trump. Barely
covered in yesterday Sunday shows. I'm going
to get into that and I have a 47 second video
for you. 47 seconds of video that exposes
the real Donald Trump. I'll explain all of
this later on. Huge news weekend, and I'm
glad you're with me today.